not for support here that that is a
military code of the Choctaw Nation
I can understand it neither could the
Germans
[Music]
our story starts in the Western Front
during World War one the Allies are in
trouble
the Germans had tapped their phone lines
and deciphered their codes as the Allies
struggled to find a solution one captain
overheard two of his Native American
Choctaw soldiers speaking their
mother-tongue King took MA and the
captain overheard the two soldiers
speaking their native language they
probably thought they were in really big
trouble
that's neutrino shobha hi there
great-granddaughter one of those two
soldiers and president of the Choctaw
code talkers Association around this
time if we talk to our cut speaking the
language they were liable to be sent
away to a re-education program but the
captain he had a different idea if I
can't understand what they're saying
perhaps the Germans won't understand
what they're saying the US military
began transmitting technical messages in
Choctaw and unsurprisingly the Germans
could not break the code not all
military terms had a direct translation
machine gun washing horse fall Obama was
little glance shoot fast ammunition
Aussie lucky with arrows and gas body
although bad air
and due at least in part to the Choctaw
code talkers and their neologisms the
war ended soon thereafter when you look
at how ironic it is for the government
to say you can't speak your language but
yet they used them to help win war one
that's pretty amazing to me
[Music]
[Applause]